[Musique]
et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
philippe martinez bonjour bonjour si
beaucoup d'être avec nous au secrétaire
général de la cgt on est ensemble
pendant 20 minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse quotidienne
régionale représenter ce matin par denis
carot bonjour denis bonjour ravi doit
voir sur ce plateau directeur des
rédactions du groupe nice matin
on va commencer avec vous philippe
martinez par ces mobilisations hier la
cgt qui a appelé à une journée de
mobilisation pour défendre les emplois
réclamer notamment des hausses de
salaires alors il ya quelques milliers
de personnes qui ont défilé dans
plusieurs villes de france mais on a
l'impression que cette manifestation
elle est quand même passé un peu
inaperçu quel regard vous avez vos
lendemain de cette manifestation est ce
que vous vous dites on a raté notre coup
un produit tout fait cette journée
d'action était encore plus justifié avec
la symbolique de l'annnonce de la phase
2 du projet de fermeture de l'usiné de
bridgestone à béthune région je pense
ces essais c'est un marqueur pour cette
rentrée où il ya eu beaucoup de
promesses durant la période de
confinement du président de la
république
rappelez vous les premiers de corvée les
indispensables à la république qui est
non soit n'ont pas vu arriver les primes
et surtout les hausses de salaires pour
des gens indispensables mais qui
subissent comme les autres des plans de
restructuration donc cette journée est
indispensable dans des conditions que
tout le monde connaît c'est à dire c'est
la santé la difficulté à manifester en
respectant les gestes barrière beaucoup
de retraités nous ont dit on reviendra
pas voilà c'est des réalités aussi mais
cette journée elle était allée elle est
allée marquant parce qu'elle exprime une
colère qui est parfois cacher parfois
étouffé mais qui est très présente
alors justement cette manifestation
c'est le journée elle était actée depuis
depuis le mois de juillet bien avant
l'annoncé de la fermeture de bridgestone
est ce qu'il était raisonnable de la
maintenir dans ces conditions sanitaires
oui oui parce que
il ya enfin on nous a reproché de
dirhams et jean castex arrive vous êtes
déjà dans une journée d'action se sait
pas on doit être visionnaire oui c'est
automatique dans dans dans la
mobilisation là on a demandé au premier
ministre
les paroles on a dit c'est les paroles
c'est bien mais les actes c'est mieux et
dans ses premiers propos il y avait
beaucoup de concertation dialogue ça
c'est des trucs on entend même si
peut-être que lui donne des consignes
ont ces ministres pour qu'on parle plus
ensemble mais la réalité c'est que les
plans sociaux faim de contes dits
sociaux les plans de restructuration se
multiplient on refuse d'augmenter les
salaires le cdur de la santé le moins
qu'on puisse dire ne fait pas
l'unanimité parmi les parcelles et
soignants il ya deux nouveaux conflits
dans les hôpitaux
voilà c'est vous semblez aussi critiqué
la méthode reste ex parmi vous semblez
aussi critiqué la méthode castex il n'y
a pas de dialogue ou et le dialogue ça
suffit pas mais il existe des dialogues
bien il existe mais ça ne suffit pas on
parle on parle plus qu'avant c'est vrai
qu'à mais c'est à dire puisque al khidr
philippe queulin gouvernement précédent
mais ça ne suffit pas de dialoguer il
faut c'est pas les petites conversations
au coin du feu qu'il faut c'est on parle
et on agit or de ce point de vue là on
peut discuter du plan de relance qui est
une des symboliques
c'est si on continue comme avant on
donne beaucoup d'argent aux grandes
entreprises
et puis je vous ai cité des exemples
phares et les aides à domicile par
exemple qui sont vraiment des salariés
qu'on connaît bien dans les territoires
indispensable dans les territoires elles
sont ni reconnu ni mieux payés elles ont
les problèmes de qualification
voilà un exemple concret qui méritaient
qui mériterait des réponses concrètes
on les a pas on va parler de ces plans
sociaux dans quelques instants avec de
nîmes et dernière question sur cette
mobilisation
il ya très peu de syndicats qui ont qui
ont suivi votre appel hier et notamment
force ouvrière ne l'a pas suivi est ce
qu'aujourd'hui la cgt est isolé parmi
les 59 ans mais t'es pas tout seul vous
l'avez noté l'avait fait il ya les
solidaires exactement et puis force
ouvrière a fait un communiqué vous
l'avez sans doute lui qui dit à peu près
la même chose qu'eux
communiqué intersyndical mais qui pour
des raisons internes doit doit discuter
avec ses instances et il n'y a pas de
problème de ce point de vue là n'ont pas
de problème la cgt n'est pas isolé la
cgt n'est pas isolé et derniers mois il
ya une autre date
une prochaine manifestation qui est
prévu une prochaine date de mai on est
en fait en tire les enseignements de ce
qui s'est passé hier on réfléchit on
discute avec d'autres il faut aussi se
mobiliser autour des plans de
restructuration qui existe dans nombre
de secteurs et donc
donc on ne sait pas d'appel à manifester
dans la rue vous serez informés
rapidement l'appareil dénoncer le port
alors les plans sociaux on le voit se
multiplient tout le monde est sous le
choc de l'annoncé de la fermeture de
bridgestone
alors que visiblement les choses étaient
été préparée était dans les tuyaux 8 163
emplois supprimés cette annonce vous
elle vous a surpris
elle n'est pas surprenante le problème
c'est quand les syndicats alertent et là
c'est pas que la cgt
dans ce cas là en disant il faut des
investissements
personne ne nous écoute et il faut une
telle décision pour que tout le monde se
crier au scandale etc
mais pourquoi on n'écoute pas avant
c'est ça le problème on a l'impression
que quand on dit attention il faut
investir attention il faut moderniser
attention il faut rééquilibrer les
productions les traîtres les différents
sites
personne n'écoute et il faut une telle
décision pour que la alors là c'est tout
le monde
tout le monde crie au scandale etc mais
c'est avant qu'il faut agir et c'est
avant qu'il faut faire pression sur les
entreprises quand on est des entreprises
parce que les milliards coule à flots
cice crédit impôt recherche est
aujourd'hui le plan de relance à quoi
sert cet argent c'est là qu'il faut
s'inquiéter et qu'il faut exiger que cet
argent soit faire soit placé ou en tout
cas investit pour l'avenir des sites
est ce que vous avez prévu de vous
rendre à béthune pour soutenir les
jeunes et jules et mes petits camarades
de béthune hier
on est en train de réfléchir enfin en
train de regarder comment je peux
contribuer je ne suis pas un homme
providentiel
il ya des rendez vous il semble y avoir
des rendez vous au ministère avec la
région et c'est une réunion notamment
lundi entre élus et savoir ce qu'il en
est mais en tout cas oui oui si je peux
être utile
j'irai mais pour l'instant c'est pas la
date n'est pas fixée mais bruno le maire
qui dénonce une décision révoltante nous
allons nous battre dit-il est ce que
vous serez au côté du gouvernement
je serai aux côtés des salariés parce
que c'est ceux qui ont le plus besoin
des syndicats savaient bruno le maire
c'est pas la première fois qu'ils qui
s'indigne il l'a fait la semaine
dernière sur general electric
le ton était moins vif mais enfin
c'était la même chose mais je peux
multiplier on peut multiplier les fois
où il s'est indigné il a il faut des
actes et des résultats pas des paroles
et c'est là où il ya un problème parce
que le plan de relance aujourd'hui c'est
la continuité de ce qu'on faisait avant
avec je vous ai cité quelques exemples
est ce que l'état peut faire quelque
chose sur le dossier
bridgestone agnès manière une hache et a
expliqué que le gouvernement est prêt à
faire du bruit ça signe un peu comme un
aveu de faiblesse prête à faire du bruit
ça vous fait sourire oui parce que quand
nous on manifeste et ont fait du bruit
on nous critique
j'avais pas vu dans la manif d'ailleurs
agnès pannier rue nash et hier non plus
sérieusement il ya oui l'état peut faire
quelque chose
yonhap il y en a assez des petites
phrases qui dit l'état ne peut pas tout
l'état ne peut pas faire enfin c'est
vieux comme comme la vème république
j'ai l'impression il faut être exigeant
il faut contrôler plus les entreprises
et donc par exemple les fabrications qui
sont faites à béthune elles vont être
répartis sur d'autres sites
dire qu'on va faire travailler plus des
gens ailleurs avec des taux d'engagement
les entreprises qui dépassent les 100 %
dans des conditions de travail
déplorables bien on peut exiger un plan
de bridgestone qui répartissent mieux
les productions avec habitude le besoin
de fabriquer des produits
plus adapté aux voitures d'aujourd'hui
parce que il fa il fabrique depuis
quelques années plus tôt des fins de
séries que des pneus adaptés aux
voitures d'aujourd'hui voilà et puis il
faut des réponses
et si c'est pas le cas il faut
rembourser les aides publiques
nous nous considérons qu ils font même
mettre des amendes quand on ne tient pas
ses engagements et bien faut être punis
et donc il faut mettre des amendes et
qui permettent éventuellement de
moderniser le site elaph clairement ça
veut dire quoi une entreprise qui reçoit
des aides publiques
il va y avoir des contreparties si les
contreparties ne sont pas respectés des
amendes il faut que ce soit la
conditionner à je te donne de l'argent
pour quoi faire
il faut que ça soit formalisée comme un
contrat comme un contrat et si le
contrat n'est pas respecté
non seulement en bourse mais on est
punis bridgestone c'est l'arbre qui
cache la forêt des notamment de beaucoup
de petites entreprises qui sont en
difficulté et qui risquent de mettre la
clé sous la porte dans les semaines et
les mois qui viennent et la petite forêt
qui 10 h la grande forêt il ya tout tout
tout tout les jours il ya enfin auchan
le moins qu'on puisse dire c'est que la
grande distribution pendant qu'on filme
ans elle a fait travailler salariés
parce qu'ils étaient indispensables ils
n'ont pas perdu d'argent loin de là et
bien 1500 suppressions d'emplois auchan
a touché des aides aussi public qu'est
ce qu'on fait airbus parce que là il ya
un maillage de sous traitants très
important parfois on nous reproche de
parler que des grands groupes mais
derrière le grand groupe il ya des tas
de petites entreprises là aussi je pense
à affichage dans le lot par exemple il
ya les pme tpe qui bossent pour
l'aéronautique
il ya 300 commandes de plus en 2020 en
juin 2020 qu'il n'y avait en juin 2019
comment plutôt que d'annoncer des
licenciements tout de suite parce que
c'est ça aujourd'hui
eh bien on dit on réfléchit comment
éviter ces licenciements chez le donneur
d'ordre et chez les sous traitants par
la formation par le choc le chômage
partiel de longue durée par peut-être
une inde générique qui travaillent sur
des nouveaux projets on licencie d'abord
et on réfléchit après faut remettre les
choses à l'endroit parce que c'est
toujours les salariés qui
et ça veut dire que la subvention vous
entendre depuis qu'on parle de ce sujet
ça veut dire que l'état laisse trop
faire bien sûr très clairement les états
et est pour le moins bienveillants
vis-à-vis des entreprises qui reçoivent
de l'argent et qui en revanche ne donne
aucune garantie oui les tailles et
bienveillant et très bienveillant seul
plan de relance sur le plan de relance
un plan d'une ampleur inédite 100
milliards le prolongement du chômage
partiel
est-ce que vous reconnaissez que le
gouvernement fait les efforts
nécessaires pour soutenir les salariés
sur le sur le montant oui c'est assez
exceptionnel
d'ailleurs en janvier il n'y avait pas
d'argent dans ce pays voit que
maintenant il ya de l'argent
voici une bonne nouvelle pour vous qui
est de l'argent maintenant on l'avait
dit on on l'avait dit en janvier qu'il y
avait de l'argent on nous disait c'est
pas vrai les déficits les dettes etc
vous voyez quand on quand on veut on
trouve de l'argent ça c'est la première
chose par contre à quoi il sert or pour
l'instant le plan de relance c'est la
continuité ce que je vous disais tout à
l'heure c'était convened les entreprises
pour quoi faire
pour quoi faire le chômage de longue
durée c'est conditionné à des accords
d'actes de compétitivité esther que on
dit pas on va continuer à vous payer 84%
je le signale parce que certains
salariés est même à 100% ils finissent
pas et fins de mois six mois à 84 % ça
devient de plus en plus dur je ferme
cette parenthèse mais y met c'est
conditionné à des accords où on dit faut
accepter des baisses de salaires faut
accepter des suppressions de primes ça
peut pas être toujours les salariés qui
payent les pots cassés
et il ya des entreprises d'ailleurs
qu'il a et dernières ont versé beaucoup
d'argent à leurs actionnaires et qui
aujourd'hui pleurs et c'est pas une
image pour dire donnez nous de l'argent
pour nous aider là aussi pourquoi on
continue à verser des dividendes et aux
actionnaires on devrait l'imiter quelles
que soient les entreprises les
dividendes versés aux actionnaires pour
que cet argent ait servi
ils servent par exemple a payé à 100%
les salariés à investir et c'est donc ce
plan de relance c'est un plan de
continuité
d'abord nous ont réclamé un plan de
rupture et on a des tas de projets sur
la table un bruno le maire estime que la
conditionnalité que vous avez que vous
avez évoqué freinerait la relance il
propose de son côté une charte des
contreparties aux entreprises est ce que
ça pourrait être une piste mais je les
ai entendus puisque je les croise et
lundi dernier dans le cadre du conseil
national de l'industrie avec le premier
ministre
ça veut dire quoi une charte ccc des
conseils c'est si vous pouvez essayer
d'appliquer la charte
ça ne marche pas ça ça ne marche pas tu
fais des obligations il faut des
obligations un contrat je vous prête de
l'argent je vous donne de l'argent par
contre vous vous m'assurer des
investissements des emplois de la
formation l'embauché des jeunes parce
que le plan jeunes c'est on donne de
l'argent pour des alternants des
apprentis mais mais à la fin de cette
période c'est un cdi ou c'est la porte
c'est une vraie question ça devrait être
un cdi
on forme des jeunes et à la fin de leur
l'ordre leur apprentissage on leur serre
la main on dit merci d'être venu aller
retour au chômage se séparent
on peut pas traiter la jeunesse comme ça
sur la réforme des retraites le
gouvernement qui se dit toujours aussi
volontariste 1 sur 7
pas très clair
réforme des retraites en tout cas jean
castex dit qu'il travaille encore
qu'elle n'est pas abandonné le
gouvernement parle même d'une
réouverture des discussions avec les
partenaires sociaux est ce que vous êtes
prêts à retourner discuter avec le
gouvernement de ce sujet est-ce que s'il
ya des négociations des concertations
qui sont ouvertes la cgt ira comme
d'habitude mais on va pas repartir à
zéro
enfin je veux dire on va pas repartir
comme comme au mois de janvier et enfin
soit on relance les hostilités c'est le
cas de le dire
il repart dans des choses qu'on a vécu
soit on remet les compteurs à zéro
on remet les compteurs à zéro et de ce
point de vue la personne ne peut nous
reprocher de ne pas avoir fait des
propositions on n'est pas d'accord avec
cette réforme systémique mais on a fait
des propositions
on avait même prévu le confinement nous
nous et nous et empêcher de faire notre
propre conférence de financement avec
beaucoup de syndicats d'ailleurs on
n'était pas du tout isolée avec des
experts avec des des économistes qui ne
sont pas du tout d'accord avec la cgt
mais qui pense qui a besoin de réfléchir
autrement cette réforme des retraites et
le problème des retraites comme de la
sécurité sociale c'est si vous fermer
les robinets
il n'y a plus d'argent pour financer
notre système qui quand même a fait a
fait les preuves de son efficacité de
son utilité dans les rangs cette période
or que propose le gouvernement à chaque
fois c'est dire aux entreprises vous
rendez compte
elles ont pas de sous donc on les
exonère de cotisations bas si on les
exonère de cotisations elles ne
contribuent pas la solidarité nationale
tout le monde doit y contribuer sur la
sur la crise sanitaire le gouvernement a
fait le choix de privilégier des mesures
territorialisée et compte notamment sur
les préfets comme à bordeaux et à
marseille en début de semaine le préfet
des alpes maritimes doit d'ailleurs
faire des annonces
aujourd'hui à nice ce choix des
décisions au plus près du terrain est ce
que c'est c'est la bonne solution
gab ya besoin de faire des choix au plus
près du terrain oui parce qu'il ya des
réalités qui sont différentes en terme
de pandémie etc
par contre qu'il faut veiller c'est tous
les territoires bénéficient de l'égalité
qui est le symbole de notre république
on peut pas avoir des mesures par
exemple en matière de masquer ce qu'on a
connu d'ailleurs
où on dit en région dit au département
débrouillez-vous pour fournir des
masques et parce que les réalités
économiques des régions des départements
ne sont pas les mêmes ça peut pas être
les les plus riches qui s'en sortent et
les plus pauvres qui souffrent donc il
ya besoin oui d'adapter parce que la
pandémie
l'évolution de la pandémie n est pas
pareil dans les grandes métropoles
là on parle beaucoup de bordeaux
marseille il faut des mesures adaptées
mais en veillant bien à ce qu' il y ait
égalité des citoyens y compris dans
certains territoires
ça peut pas être la métropole au
détriment des zones périphériques par
exemple alors on a vu que certains
maires et c'est le cas de christian
estrosi à nice était très offensif dans
cette crise sanitaire
il a été un des premiers à imposer le
port du masque dans sa ville ses élus
est-ce qu'ils ont raison mais enfin il
faut là aussi il faudrait enfin ça il
faut des règles parce que comme en
sicile n'y a pas un peu plus de
visibilité nationale
les gens peuvent se dire mais pourquoi
pourquoi ici et c'est d'ailleurs des
interrogations vous savez il y avait des
endroits où des quartiers étaient
fallait le mas d'autres quartiers
fallait pas dont il faut il faut
évidemment des prendre en compte les
situations locales mais toujours veillé
à cette notion d'égalité alors je et
puis là aussi sur les masques tout le
monde n'est pas traité de la même façon
ça coûte cher les masques nous on
propose la gratuité
et puis selon là où vous travaillez il
faut des masques particulier c'est pas
le cas encore aujourd'hui ça peut pas
être une décision d'un maire sans faire
de mauvais procès pour des raisons ou
d'un président de région puisque c'est
d'actualité en ce moment qui dit vous
avez vu chez moi moi je donne les moyens
quand on a les moyens on peut les donner
et là on perd la notion d'égalité il ya
des tas de familles notamment avec des
enfants scolarisés qui souffrent parce
qu'elles n'ont pas les moyens de se
payer des masques ça c'est de la sas et
la république qui doit s'occuper de sa
part le maire ou le président de région
où les et veyran qui dit qu'il fournit
les mascarons familles les plus
précaires à un mot puisque vous parlez
de ces entreprises ou maintenant le port
du masque est obligatoire
comme dans beaucoup d'endroits
d'ailleurs quels sont les remontées que
vous avez des salariés des entreprises
c'est ce que ça se passe bien il ya des
problèmes mais quel problème du problème
si quand on s'est passé une journée fin
vous le savez vous avez des périodes où
vous l'avez pas mais dans les emplois
pendant les entreprises à l'école même
pendant la récréation dalmas est donc
passé 8h ou 9h avec un masque sur la
figure c'est pas facile donc il ya des
salariés qui essayent de respirer ça
peut être une un motif de sanction par
exemple à ce que l'on respecte pas ce
qu'il faut c'est adapté oui il faut le
port du masque mais selon les selon les
situations au travail il faut adapter
par exemple on sait que dans les zones
dans les milieux humides aux abattent
dans les abattoirs l'efficacité du
masque est plus faible dans la durée
qu'ailleurs comment on change les
masques il faut des temps de pause où je
suis pas toutes les heures dans l'est
dans la distribution mais ailleurs dans
l'industrie on devait avoir des temps de
pause pour aller dans des endroits où on
peut respirer à tour de rôle donc le
port du masque c'est indispensable mais
sur les sur les lieux de travail il faut
une organisation du travail qui permet
aussi que ça n'accentue pas les
mauvaises conditions de travail de ce
point de vue là là aussi le gouvernement
fait des recommandations
et puis les employeurs vont piocher dans
des guides mais ce qu'ils ne
s'intéressent pas ils sont pas obligés
de l'appliquer
les accord de télétravail se multiplient
dans l'est dans les entreprises est ce
que globalement ça va plutôt dans le
sens des salariés
il faut sur le télétravail et c'est ce
qu'on reproche aux medays qui ne veut
pas négocier
y a pas de négociation il faut un cadre
national qu'on prenne en compte des
spécificités là c'est pareil
d'entreprise etc
mais il faut un cadre national qui
fournit le matériel comme en compte les
heures de travail
comment on voit confier en sorte que
parce que ce qu'on a vécu c'était pas du
télétravail quand on travaille on n'a
pas les enfants à la maison où on
partage pas son ordinateur avec son
conjoint de sa conjointe qui vérifie que
le poste de travail à la maison il ne va
pas générer des problèmes de lombalgie
des trucs et des choses comme ça donc ça
c'est que ça doit être un cadre national
et pour l'instant on n'a pas donc on a
des accords dans les entreprises qui
sont dans un certain nombre d'endroits
très aléatoire sur un certain nombre de
questions
c'est pas possible il va y avoir des
discussions avec le patronat dès la
semaine prochaine je crois patronat
refuse de négocier pour l'instant il
faut faire un diagnostic mais enfin le
télétravail ce pas nouveau il ya déjà un
accord national qui a été remise à mal
par des ordonnances du gouvernement
diagnostic qui est fait le télétravail
ça doit être encadrée à les dernières
questions philippe martin est sur cette
image qui a fait polémique hier au sein
de l'assemblée nationale
une syndicaliste de l'unef qui s'est
présentée voilée devant une commission
de l'assemblée nationale certains
députés ont quitté la commission la
députée la république en marche
anne-christine lang a notamment déploré
qu'une personne vienne voilée devant
cette commission dénonçant une marque de
soumission qu'est ce que vous en pensez
il faut que la république est laïque et
donc tout ce qui est symbole de la
république doit respecter cette laïcité
je pense que c'est important donc cela
veut dire qu'elle n'aurait pas dû se
présenter voile et à l'assemblée
nationale qu en ont certainement dû
discuter avec elle avant sur les
conditions de sa venue s'est pas il faut
respecter
il ya le droit à pratiquer etc mais ça
peut pas il faut rester la laïcité c'est
essentiel dans notre pays merci beaucoup
merci philippe martinez lamartine ou
merci denis caron directeur des
rédactions du groupe nice matin va
peut-être voir d'ailleurs la une de
nice-matin aujourd'hui consacré donc à
ces mesures qui seront annoncées dans
les prochaines heures dans votre ville
denise de ninis ça va piquer merci
d'avoir été avec nous lundi à votre
place ce sera cedrico le secrétaire
d'état chargé de la transition numérique
on passe sous tito club des territoires